merci d'être avec nous Daniel grimier
elle nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes sénateur
les républicains des Vosges rapporteur
du projet de loi sur la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires dont
l'examen a débuté hier au Sénat on va
bien sûr longuement parler dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité c'est
évidemment la réforme des retraites et
on l'a vu la mobilisation se prépare les
premiers chiffres annoncent une
mobilisation importante est-ce que selon
vous la rue est à même de faire plier le
gouvernement sur ce texte
je sais pas si elle est capable de le
faire plier je pense qu'il y a le temps
pour tout il y a le temps pour le débat
il y a le temps pour l'action aussi
syndicale il est important que les
organisations syndicales fassent se
fasse entendre que la population se
fasse entendre mais il faut que tout ça
se passe dans un certain délire une
manière très apaisée et on l'a vu sur le
sujet qu'on avait à tout à l'heure on
est bien plus efficace pour servir notre
pays pour servir nos concitoyens et à
l'occurrence la forme des retraites et
les nécessaires je crois que ce qu'on
vient de voir à l'instant et ce qui a
été dit par le président du Sénat hier
on veut confirme bien le positionnement
depuis quatre ans du Sénat on voit bien
que c'est mathématiques
[Musique]
évolutions et l'ambition que nous avons
de mieux vieillir de pouvoir
rendre plus tard dans la vie active
nécessite cette réforme
et je souhaite vraiment que tant au
Sénat comme à l'assemblée qui est un
travail de quel que soit nos
sensibilités mais qui est un travail de
fond dans l'intérêt de la société dans
l'intérêt des Français c'est des
Français il y a des sujets on parle
beaucoup de l'âge mais il y a beaucoup
de choses qui restent vraiment à bien
préciser quand on parle une évolution du
niveau de la retraite pour tous alors
parfois on nous dit des on nous apporte
des garanties pour les nouveaux entrants
mais quid encore des sujets qui vous
inquiète alors sur l'âge comme le Sénat
a voté ça j'imagine que vous n'avez pas
d'objection sur un rapport de l'Agence
64 ans mais est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qui vous inquiètent dans cette réforme
qui nous inquiète qui nécessite encore
de travailler c'est sûr effectivement et
il est annoncé 1200 euros de retraite
au minimum autoplan
pour une carrière complète mais la
question qui est posée c'est de savoir
celle et ceux qui sont déjà en retraite
s'ils ont accès ou pas pour ce qui est
du Sénat nous considérons qu'il est
nécessaire que tout le monde se traitait
du maire équitable un autre aspect qui a
aussi encore à peaufiner c'est la prise
en compte au niveau des maires de
famille par rapport aux enfants et par
rapport aux années cotisées ça fait
partie des points sur lesquels vous
savez le Sénat est très attaché à la
famille je fais partie des points où il
y a nécessité d'avoir des garanties
d'avoir des avancées qui consolides
effectivement cette évolution sur la
retraite donc encore des discussions à
avoir selon vous c'est pas votre vote
n'est pas encore acquis
sur effectivement ce que j'ai voté de
d'ailleurs depuis quatre ans au Sénat et
je suis très attaché effectivement à ces
points là et je suis aussi très attaché
par rapport aux carrières longues et
notamment je pense à celles et ceux qui
ont travaillé très jaune très jeunes il
faut aussi je serai tenter de dire un
nombre d'années maximum de par rapport
au cotisations et tenir compte aussi par
rapport à la notion pénabilité et
pénibilité qui est très importante aussi
on va parler d'une autre actualité c'est
cette incendie qui s'est déclaré
avant-hier sur un site logistique dans
la banlieue de Rouen alors vous vous
avez travaillé sur la commission
d'enquête Lubrizol même si les
situations ne sont pas identiques a
priori pas de pollution pas de pollution
dans l'air après cet incendie à Rouen
mais quand même est-ce que cette
incitime pose à nouveau la question de
la réglementation de ces sites
industriels
c'était d'ailleurs très intéressant
parce que on était tous sous l'émotion
et d'ailleurs quand lorsqu'on s'est
rendu avec la coefficient d'enquête sur
les lieux
ça vous marque et on se rend compte que
tout le travail de cette commission
d'enquête n'a pas été vain puisque
aujourd'hui à nouveau un point a été
fait par la Commission de développement
durable avec notamment
un travail important de Pascal Martin et
champion qui précise que les 80% des
recommandations de ce que nous avions
nous estimé nécessaire de mettre en
oeuvre suite à cet incendie
euh a été réellement mise en œuvre
aujourd'hui il y a encore des points
qu'il faut améliorer effectivement ces
informations du public c'est c'est
nécessaire c'est l'information des
maires des collectivités c'est aussi à
d'aller encore plus loin sur la
connaissance des matières notamment qui
peuvent exister sur un site parce qu'on
soit bien clair
formation
ce qu'il y a dans le ces usines qui sont
pourtant sur leur commune non c'est
rendu compte à l'époque et ça ça fait
partie des points
si on avait déclenché et je crois que je
crois la décision du préfet de des
services incendie lorsque l'incendie
s'est déclaré ils avaient soit le choix
de faire sonner effectivement des
sirènes qui étaient l'élément
déclencheur de l'information ce qui
aurait mis
pour conséquence de mettre les gens dans
les rues pour
quelque part partir quitter le lieu
alors que il fallait plutôt que ces
populations restent confinées donc on se
rend bien compte que là aussi il y a
degrés d'informations la sirène n'est
pas la meilleure des informations
la connaissance des matières sur un site
et la recombinaison de celle-ci
lorsqu'il y a un sinistre un incendie
peuvent aussi être dangereuses et puis
l'autre aspect donc un travail à faire
avec les industriels et puis ensuite il
y a le suivi le suivi à la fois
des populations donc on se rend compte
qu'il y a eu énormément d'analyses qui
ont été réalisés de suivi au niveau de
la santé humaine ça doit être prolongé
dans le temps il faut pas que ça soit
uniquement sous loup ou je dirais de
l'immédiat mais que ça soit prolongé
dans le temps et puis l'autre remarque
c'est la nécessité de quelque part
trouver une cohérence entre toutes ces
analyses avoir une multitude d'analyses
et ne pas à un moment donné faire de
recoupements de croisement entre les
informations qu'on peut avoir sur la
santé humaine et des informations qu'on
peut avoir sur la santé des sols des
plantes de la nature serait une
erreur c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
effectivement il faut aller plus loin on
va parler nucléaire parce que vous êtes
rapporteur du texte qui est examiné
depuis hier dans l'hémicycle du Sénat on
va voir les temps forts de cette
première séance avec Steve Jourdain
[Musique]
ont donc entamé l'examen d'un texte sur
l'accélération du nucléaire en France
comme promis par Emmanuel Macron de quoi
parle-t-on d'un texte horriblement
technique les mots sont pas de moi ils
sont de la ministre de la transition
énergétique en espagnol une haché oui
c'est un texte technique Oriane
puisqu'il ne porte pas sur le principe
de la construction de nouvelles
centrales nucléaire qui fera l'objet
d'un autre débat mais sur le volet
administratif de cette construction et
le gouvernement assume écouter
le projet de loi qui nous rassemble
aujourd'hui marque une nouvelle phase de
notre politique nucléaire en
introduisant un cadre d'accélération du
processus d'autorisation administrative
pour les futurs projets nucléaires hier
il était donc question que ninopération
simplification pour le gouvernement dans
le détail le projet de loi prévoit
notamment de dispenser les projets de
réacteur d'autorisation d'urbanisme de
limiter les voies de contentieux
dorénavant les recours seront
directement traités par le Conseil
d'État ou encore de faciliter les
procédures d'expropriation toutes ces
mesures devraient nous permettre de
gagner deux trois ans dans le démarrage
des chantiers selon les calculs des
spécialistes pour la majorité
sénatoriale tout ça c'est très bien et
ça vient un peu trop tard à écouter
s'il fallait trouver un titre qui
correspondent précisément aux objectifs
affichés j'opterais volontiers pour
l'oeuvre de Marcel Proust à la recherche
du temps perdu
c'est en effet parce que l'exécutif
procrastine depuis 10 ans sur la
question du nucléaire que nous devons en
catastrophe envisager les voix et moyen
d'accélérer pour permettre de renouveler
notre parc de réacteurs nucléaire
on est propositions les modifications
apportées par le Sénat les sénateurs
veulent transformer ce texte très
technique en texte politique ils veulent
pousser le gouvernement a vraiment
accélérer sur le nucléaire et à parler
de sa stratégie en matière énergétique
un amendement en particulier a été très
discuté c'est le vote monsieur le
rapporteur il prévoit de supprimer
l'objectif de 50% de nucléaires dans la
production en 2035 en d'autres termes
les sénateurs veulent augmenter la part
qu'on prévoit de consacrer au nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique pour les années
à venir le gouvernement est contre il
dit vouloir attendre avant de trancher
il souhaite le faire dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation plus réanuel de
l'énergie qui sera présentée dans le
courant de l'année tout ça nous amène
une question de fond Oriane faut-il ou
non relancer la filière du nucléaire
pour les écologistes la réponse est non
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire s'oppose au fondement même du
projet la relance du nucléaire il n'est
pas acceptable de relancer des activités
nucléaires polluantes et dangereuses qui
nous engagent sur au moins un siècle
alors que les menaces de tous ordres et
en particulier les bouleversements
climatiques vont accroître de façon
considérable et risque encourus par
cette filière monsieur sénateur sur le
principe ça y est le nucléaire a gagné
c'est pas le nucléaire a gagné il y a
urgence que le gouvernement que le
Parlement prenne ses responsabilités
nous vivons aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'énergie électrique je ne cesse de
répéter sur les décisions stratégiques
de l'époque du général de Gaulle de
Pompidou et du Giscard d'Estaing donc et
on a rien fait depuis donc globalement
puisqu'on avait il avait été lancé super
Phénix Astrid tout ça ce sont des
projets qui ont été arrêtés soit par le
président et fermeture des deux
réacteurs de Fessenheim président
Hollande ou le président Macron donc
aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte de la
fragilité la France était pendant des
décennies leaders sur à la fois une
énergie suffisante pour les populations
accessibles aux populations accessibles
aussi dans des conditions de
compétitivité pour notre économie et les
collectivités aujourd'hui on se rend
bien compte de notre agilité et ça a été
d'ailleurs dit par la ministre on a
devant nous un mur d'investissement
terrible puisque d'ici 2050 c'est
[Musique]
ne sera plus un sujet mais je reviens
sur le choix qui avait été fait sur
Astrid qui consiste puis qui nous
permettait d'utiliser l'uranium appauvri
comme à nouveau un combustible ce qui
nous fait permettait d'avoir une
projection pratiquement d'un siècle de
de matière pour faire fonctionner une
centrale donc on a tué derrière ça
c'était la recherche c'était
l'innovation pourquoi aujourd'hui
avons-nous perdu les compétences et
c'est pour ça que en tant que rapporteur
et ça a été repris et voté au niveau du
Sénat je suis vraiment content du débat
apaisé qu'il y a eu pendant hier et
cette nuit puisque nous avons même
terminé l'examen de ce texte qui a été
clos dans dans la nuit et cet examen il
nous a permis effectivement de redonner
à la fois cette lisibilité qui va
encourager à des jeunes à des
investisseurs de se lancer effectivement
dans ces formations il va permettre
effectivement
de sécuriser moi j'ai souhaité deux
choses en tant que rapporteur simplifier
sécuriser tenir compte et aujourd'hui de
l'évolution climatique
par exemple lorsqu'on a une centrale en
bord de mer j'ai renforcé la sécurité
tenant compte de l'érosion tenant compte
de l'élévation du niveau de la mer des
vagues sur merci etc ce sont des sujets
et puis un autre point que j'ai renforcé
aussi dans le texte c'est la cyber
résilience on voit bien que les risques
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas plus les
risques d'hier
on parlait de l'amendement qui a
beaucoup été discuté hier votre
abonnement qui prévoit de supprimer cet
objectif de 50% de nucléaire dans la
production en 2035 le gouvernement n'est
pas d'accord avec vous
comment ça va se passer comment quelle
suite vous voyez à ce texte ouais
écoutez pour ce qui est du Sénat le
votre solennel a lieu le 24 la semaine
prochaine je crois savoir que
l'accordéon de l'Assemblée un peu
décalée puisque la ministre nous
évoquait hier que il serait à
l'Assemblée fin mars plutôt en avril
comment ça va se passer je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le Sénat et le travail
sénatorial là aussi qui n'est pas un
travail au doigt mouillé c'est pas en
2023 soudainement qu'on considère qui
nécessaire de relancer la politique
nucléaire ça fait plusieurs années ça
fait plusieurs années rapports et
notamment le gouvernement d'accord vous
êtes d'accord sur le principe en fait ce
qui qu'est-ce qui diverge entre vous et
le gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est la
proportion du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique vous pouvez pas d'un côté
dire on veut une loi d'urgence on veut
une loi de simplification qui écrase je
dirais tenté de dire toutes les mesures
en matière d'urbanisme et et dans le
même pas le même temps considérait
considéré ce qui est nécessaire de
fermer les centrales on vit toujours
dans une contradiction terrible pour
qu'on soit clair c'est que c'est quoi la
bonne part on est aujourd'hui à 70%
c'est quoi la bonne part pour vous du
nucléaire dans le mixe
on est à 70% je vous rappelle que le
débat il est sur 50% vous voyez la
c'est la première fois que le Parlement
va débattre de cette projection au
niveau de l'orientation des choix
stratégiques pour l'énergie c'est
essentielle pour les familles c'était
essentiel pour notre économie et c'est
essentiel par la collectivité l'énergie
et je rappelle aussi un point que j'ai
fait passer dans qui a été voté au Sénat
c'est que nous avons renforcé la place à
la fois pour nos concitoyens dans la
part du débat ensuite sur l'accélération
et sur la sécurité mais quand je vois le
défi que nous avons
et sur le 50%, il est essentiellement
fait pour relancer
les investissements relancer les
compétences aujourd'hui vous ne tirez
pas de vous donnerez pas envie à des
jeunes on a compris que vous voulez pas
du 50% de 1030 est-ce que vous voulez du
50% mais plus tard c'est à dire à
horizon 2050 2060 vous dites on n'est
pas prêt en 2035 pour les 50%, ou vous
dites on touche pas au 70 %
bien plus simples je vous rappelle que
s'il Sénat n'avait pas été là le 50 %
c'était quand c'était en 2025
vous venez de dire et effectivement ce
sont les vrais chiffres je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui on est encore à 70%
d'origine nucléaire 13% d'origine
d'hydroélectricité ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut faut pas
regarder cet aspect énergétique
uniquement sur le nucléaire il faut le
voir aussi sur la partie de l'engagement
et de notre responsabilité par rapport à
l'évolution climatique et la neutralité
carbone 2050 si vous n'avez pas
d'énergie pilotable le débat il n'est
pas d'opposer le nucléaire avec l'éolien
avec le photovoltaïque le débat il est
de dire si on veut garantir aux Français
une énergie à tout instant et accessible
il est nécessaire d'avoir une énergie
pilotable et en termes d'énergie
pilotable vous avez du vous avez du
nucléaire vous avez l'hydroxicité alors
on pourrait faire le choix de faire
tourner des centrales au charbon comme
font les Allemands je pense pas que ce
soit le chien le cheval qui soit le
meilleur jour de combien encore une fois
pour revenir cette question c'est c'est
plus 70% que vous préconisez c'est plus
est-ce que il y a des chiffres est-ce
que c’est complexe et technique et que
vous voulez pas forcément vous avancer
là-dessus c'est pas une histoire de pas
vouloir aujourd'hui dans la loi on le
plafonne à 50%. aujourd'hui nous avons
70% je viens de vous faire éteindre
d'ici 2050 des 28
sites qui va falloir décider soit de
prolonger s'il a sécurité l'autorité de
sécurité nucléaire dit on peut prolonger
où on peut pas prolonger il y aura des
décisions d'investissement et ça va nous
conduire effectivement peut-être à 50
peut-être ça sera inférieur à 50%
d'ailleurs mais c'est la PPE qui va le
dire une dernière question
qui est toujours en vigueur qui prévoit
la fermeture de 12 réacteurs nucléaires
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire de ce décret
faut l'abandonner
c'est ce que j'ai dit très clairement
vous ne pouvez pas être dans ce cas là
c'est pas la peine de faire une loi
d'urgence dans la PPE
de la fermeture de ces 12 réacteurs
nucléaires ça doit figurer dans la PPE
dans la nouvelle
PPD
ce texte il prévoit la construction de
nouveaux opère quand vous voyez le temps
comme le perdre de Flamanville a sorti
le coup et le surcoût que ça représente
est-ce que vous êtes confiant sur la
construction de ces EPF je suis confiant
dès lors qu'effectivement on donne un
signe et qu'on donne une un lancement de
série si la France est timide si la
France n'a pas d'ambition sur cette
capacité à retrouver son indépendance et
à donner une perspective énergétique
pour les 50 prochaines années je suis
effectivement inquiet mais dès lors
qu'on donne de 7 lisibilité d'où
l'importance de supprimer cette ce 50%
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est encore à
70%. merci Steve merci Oriane à tout à
l'heure on parlera de Gérard Larcher et
de la réforme des retraites
qui a présenté ses vœux hier vous est-ce
qu'il a dit d'abord on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département
Daniel grimmy on va Épinal ou on
retrouve Catherine cloutchi compte
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes directrice départementale à
Vosges matin et vous allez nous parler
de ce qui se passe à la tête de la
région Grand Est puisque vendredi la
région Grand Est
un nouveau président pour succéder à
Jean rotner et vous allez nous raconter
cette élection
oui bonjour effectivement la région
Grand Est victime d'une certaine
malédiction avec la démission de deux
présidents Philippe Richard et Jean
rotner est-ce que est-ce que ça vous
inquiète Daniel grillé
ça m'inquiète pas du tout pour deux
raisons la première c'est que nous avons
été élus sur un projet pour la région
Grand Est
la deuxième heure raison c'est que avant
de quitter son sa responsabilité de
président
et nous avons voté un budget pour
l'année 2023 et la région Grand Est en
situation de pouvoir travailler et
depuis vendredi nous avons à nouveau un
Président nous avons à nouveau des
vice-président nous avons une commission
permanente qui est en place et qui est
en capacité d'exécuter le projet pour la
région Grand Est je souhaite tenter de
dire pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens sur notre
territoire du Grand Est il n'y aura
aucune différence l'action est se
poursuit et se poursuit dans la ligne
directrice sur lesquelles sur laquelle
nous avons été élus
et c'est important de respecter ce choix
des électrices et des électeurs et puis
elle est surtout là dans une volonté de
continuer à construire cette région qui
est absolument magnifique dans le sens
où elle apporte des perspectives sur un
territoire qui est significatif où on
peut effectivement avoir une action
efficace vous comprenez la décision de
vous en avez parlé non il nous en a pas
parlé
je crois que tout le monde a été surpris
mais la question aujourd'hui elle n'est
plus celle-là on a été tous été surpris
effectivement
il lui appartient c'est une décision
personnelle et encore une fois mon rôle
en tant qu'élu et tête de liste le
département des Vosges c'est de pouvoir
continuer à dire
à nos concitoyens aux habitants du Grand
Est aux entreprises aux collectivités du
Grand est bien voilà ce qu'on a imaginé
ce qu'on a donné comme dessin futur pour
la région Grand Est nous allons
continuer de construire ensemble et
c'est ce qui va se passer avec Franck
Leroy avec les nouvelles nominations de
vice-présidente et vice-président et
surtout avec une commission permanente
qui a été renouvelée il y aura sûrement
des ajustements d'ailleurs Franck Leroy
a annoncé quelques-uns parce que on voit
bien que entre le moment où nous avons
été élus et la situation d'aujourd'hui
le contexte économique le contexte
global a évolué à changer donc on va
vers des mesures d'urgence notamment par
rapport au milieu rural on veut donner
des signes très importants
d'accompagnement d'initiatives parce que
toute petite initiative dans le milieu
rurale ce sont des petites pépites où ce
sont des femmes et des hommes qui sont à
la manœuvre et c'est de cette manière là
qu'on relance aussi l'activité
économique dans les territoires
vous avez une autre question
oui vous êtes élu à la région Grand Est
depuis 1986 c'est un mandat qui vous
tient particulièrement à cœur et vous
êtes peut-être de 10 pour le département
des Vosges est-ce que vous pensez
comment vous pensez dans ce cadre là
continuez à défendre le département des
Vosges
dans la mesure où il y a il y a des
changements de président est-ce que
est-ce que ça vous pose un souci ça me
pose aucun souci
l'équipe encore une fois lorsqu'on a
travaillé lorsqu'en tête en tant que
tête de liste avec toute l'équipe de
femmes et d'hommes qui est composé ma
liste au niveau notre liste au niveau du
département des Vosges lorsqu'on a
effectivement
mené cette campagne électorale et bien
l'amenait avec des ambitions pour le
Grand Est des ambitions pour les Vosges
et c'est pas parce que le président a
changé que les ambitions changent de la
même manière aussi simple nous serons
proches des habitants de nos territoires
proches des acteurs économiques proche
des collectivités du maire très simple
très efficace mais surtout ce qui est
important c'est de donner toujours cette
cette ligne directrice de de partager le
chemin que l'on doit parcourir ensemble
pour répondre aux attentes de la société
des habitants du département de la
diversité de ces attentes sur le
périmètre de cette région Grand Est
puisqu'il y a encore des questions qui
se posent notamment du côté de l'Alsace
ou parce que Frédéric Berry continue à
défendre une Alsace indépendante hors de
la région Grand Est ce que vous en
pensez
pour moi c'est un nom débat je peux en
parler avec Catherine vient d'évoquer
effectivement je suis un élu depuis le
début de la décentralisation depuis la
première fois où un bulletin de vote
pour les élections régionales donc au
début j'étais cancérigenal de Lorraine
j'en étais vice-présor pendant 12 ans et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans ce grand
test et c'est vrai que le Grand Est pas
né de la volonté et d'une demande
euh des élus du territoire du Grand Est
des élus
des collectivités de la population c'est
une décision qui nous a été imposée mais
de cette décision qui nous a été imposée
on a voulu en faire une chanson et c'est
ce qu'on a fait depuis le début avec
Philippe Richard qu'on a fait qu'on a
continué de construire dans le Grand Est
pour vous et c'est évident l'Alsace
aujourd'hui est gagnante d'être dans le
grand est comme la Lorraine et
champenoise sont gagnants d'avoir
l'Alsace avec nous c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'on nous avons construit
ensemble le périmètre et le travail que
nous réalisons doit embrasser justement
cette dimension régionale qui a une
envergure qui peut nous permettre et qui
nous permet parce qu'on l'a démontré de
pouvoir mener des actions bien plus
efficaces que si on était resté dans un
laps de temps avec une région bien plus
récente merci beaucoup Daniel grémillier
merci Catherine on regarde la Une de
Vosges matin c'est le festival de
Gérardmer qui fêtera ses 30 ans et qui
débute la semaine prochaine Catherine
c'est à la Une de Vosges matin merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
Daniel grimillet dans 20 minutes dans le
club d'étatoires on parlera vous l'avez
compris de la réforme des retraites à la
veille de cette grande journée de
mobilisation des va sur la bataille
politique et puis on parlera des vœux de
Gérard archer également mais d'abord on
accueille Patrick